صباح الخير ازي حضراتكم اسمي ماجد حربي
مدير شركه من شركات الاستثمار في مجال
التعليم موجوده في مصر
وحابب ارجع معكم كده بالزمن عشرين سنه زي
النهارده كده من عشرين سنه كنت بستعد كده
امتحانات الثانويه العامه كانت والدتي
وقتها بتقول لي هات 90% وخش هندسه خلاص
كان هو ده بقى التارجت بتاعي عايز اجيب
90% وادخل
بقيت اذاكر كنت شاطر
جبت درجات كويسه الحمد لله جبت 91%
خلاص بقى متخيل نفسي كده هدخل هندسه
والدنيا هتبقى كويسه معايا وزي الفل
جيت في التنسيق زي اغلب الشباب زي زيكم
كده لو جبت الكليه تنسيق
طب ايه عمل ايه بقى جالي احباط بقى وخلاص
بقى مش عارف
فقلت خلاص كان في كليات كتير بقى ممكن
تيجي لي في الطريق بس قلت خلاص هدخل تجاره
وهكمل طريقي كده طبعا كان عندي حته احباط
طب ده انا والدتي قالت لي كده انا ايه يا
جماعه
بس يعني خلاص هكمل في الجره واطلع واشتغل
في بنك كان ده وبعدي كل سنه زي ما بتيجي
والحمد لله اتخرجت
وبدور على بنك قدمت دبلوم كتير
كذا بنك بقدم فيه في الاخر كلهم بيرفضوه
لا شكرا مش عايزني طب ايه ده ايه يا جماعه
عندي مشكله تانيه كده وانا وحش للدرجه دي
ولا ايه
فمن هنا قلت خلاص ابتدي اقدم في اي شركه
ممكن تقابلني
لغايه لما لقيت التليفون واحد بيكلمني
امريكاني كده بيقول لي عايزين نعمل معاك
انترفيو تعال لنا بكره طب يا عم حاج شركه
ايه احنا شركه جوجل
افتكرت بيهزر قلت طيب هروح اشوف رحت تاني
يوم لقيتهم فعلا جوجل
قابلني في الانترفيو اشتغلت طبعا يعني
مبسوط جدا بقى وبابايا ومامتي ايه ده انت
اشتغلت في جوجل يعني اشتغلت في شركه حلوه
قوي وباقات كويس والحياه حلوه يعني
بس لقيت بقى مشكله تانيه خالص لقيت نفسي
مش مستريح في بيئه العمل الموجوده اللي
انا كنت موجود فيها
وابتديت اتكلم مع اهلي واتكلم معاهم انهم
يا جماعه انا بشويه مش مش مبسوط اه بتعلم
حاجات حلوه جدا بتعلم ازاي اعمل سيرش
موجود في حاجه كويسه بس مش مبسوط فقلت
خليني موجود واشوف
تجالي التليفون في الفتره دي من واحد من
البنوك اللي كنت بقدم فيها قالوا لي
عايزين نعمل لك انترفيو فقلت اروح لهم مدى
حلم حياتي ورحت البنك وقبلوني
فرحت قدمت استقلت من جوجل
ورحت اشتغل في البنك طبعا ناس كثيره قالت
لي يعني عملت مشكله كبيره بس قلت لهم لا
انا حابب اشتغل في حاجه انا
دخلت ورحت اشتغلت في البنك قعدت فيه شويه
كم شهر كده بتعلم بتعلم ازاي اشتغل زي
امشي بنظام وانا بنمثل بتحب تشتغل بسيستم
ونظام الدنيا فضلت ماشيه معايا
بس برضو لقيت مش هو ده الشغل اللي انا
عايزه
لقيت حاجه تانيه اكتشفتها ان ممكن يكون
انا كنت فاكر البنك ده حاجه بنشوفها في
الافلام ناس جبت بدله حلوه وحاجه ظريفه
كده ورحت بس مش هو الحاجه اللي مريحاني
طيب يا جماعه هعمل ايه طيب يعني طب انا
كنت متخانق ليه اجمل حاجه اشتغلها
فقلت برضو خليني شغال
واتعلم حاجات واشوف لو جت لي حاجه تانيه
هشوف
فجات لي فرصه في شركه من شركات النشر
الكبيره المعروفه وموجوده هنا في مصر ممكن
اكبرهم اشتغل في حاجه اسمها التعاقدات
الاجنبيه قلت اروح وكان يعني حتى المرتب
بتاعها كان اقل من البنك شويه حلوين برضه
قالوا لي ايه ده انت مجنون وازاي تعمل كده
يعني انت هتسيب كده ورايح لابس الباب
هتروح تلبس بنطلون هناك في ايه طيب فقلت
لا هاروح
ورحت الشركه دي اشتغلت في الاداره دي
اسمها الاجنبيه كانت مهمتي اجيب توكيلات
اجنبيه زي ديزني جرافيك مجله ميكي اللي
انتم عارفينها
وبعض التوكيلات الكبيره دي ابتديت لا
قلقاني نفسي مبسوط في المكان ده مع اني
انا كنت رايح وخلاص يعني
وهنا اتعلمت حاجه تانيه ان ممكن يكون
الحاجه اللي انت نفسك فيها ممكن تبقى
موجوده
في حاجه انت مش متخيلها مش مش في البنك مش
ممكن تكون مش في جوجل على قد ما هي شركه
كبيره ومحترمه يعني
ابتديت اتطور وبكبر في الاداره دي وبترقى
ابتديت ادخل في مجالات تانيه موجوده في
نفس الاداره
الاداره دي المفروض نعمل ادارات الخدميه
اللي هي بتخدم بقيه الشركه عشان فريق
البيع يعمل المنتج والمنتج ده ينزل للسوق
وحاجات زي كده
بعد كده قلت طيب انا عايز الاداره دي كمان
تجيب او عائد
ومش مطلوب منها كده مع ان في فريق بيع
كبير في الشركه يعني اكتر من 400 واحد
فقلت خلاص ابيع في مكانهم مش بيبيعوا فيه
فقلت ابيع في امريكا وانا قاعد في مكتبي
ابتديت اجرب ابتدت تمشي عرفت ابيع في
امريكا ببيع كتب ومجلات وشويه المنتجات
اللي بتعملها الشركه
والحمد لله وصل الاراده اللي بيوصل ان هو
بيغطي
المصروف درجه نجاح كويسه وصلت ان انا بقيت
مدير اداره
المدير الاداره بتاعت التعاقدات الاجنبيه
وفي وضع كويس قوي فمبسوط
جيت بعد كده لغايه 2016
حسيبنا كل يوم بعمل نفس الشغلانه طب يا
جماعه يعني طب انا حاسس ان انا كده شويه
زهقت او حسد بنوع من انواع الملل طب هو ده
صح ولا غلط طب يعني هو اكمل كده ولا لا
احس ان انا كده هبتدي اضر نفسي واضر
المكان ان انا ممكن ما اعملش نفس الشغل
بنفس الكفاءه ونفس القدره
فقلت اتكلم مع مع رئيسه الشركه اللي هي
اسمها الاستاذ ابراهيم اللي هي فضل كبير
علي في حياتي لغايه يومنا النهارده قلت
لها قلت لها الكلام ده بكل صدق طلع بصوا
انا ليا مع حضرتك حوالي 11 سنه وقلت لكم
افضل علي على ادكو يعني اتجوزت جيت
واشتغلت واترقيت وكل حاجه حلوه بس مش هقدر
اكمل
لو جات لي فرصه تانيه فاكرين تاني انا
همشي مش عشان الشغل وحش عشان حابب ادخل في
حاجه جديده اكمل فيه
قالت لي لا استنى بعديها بكم شهر قالت لي
احنا هنعمل حاجه اسمها حاضنه اعمال وسريعه
اعمال وندخل مع الاستارت والشركات الناشئه
طبعا انا مش عارف حاجه عن الكلام ده ايه
يا جماعه شركات الناشئه
قلت لها حاضر قالت لي تعالى نتعلم ولو
تعلمتها بشكل كويس نفتح الشركه دي
سافرت امريكا سافرت الصين سافرت اكتر من
بلد وقعدنا نتعلم من المجال ده بشكل كويس
قريت كتب كثير ولقيت اعرف فهمت المجله بس
اكتشفت لما رحنا امريكا ولما روحنا الصين
للحاضنات والمسرعات وشركات الاستثمار اللي
في المجال ده كل واحد عنده نظام مختلف عن
التاني فقلت ايه يا جماعه طب احنا هنشتغل
ازاي مش عارف يعني انا عارف الاساسيات بس
مش عارف زيها كامله
جينا بعدها
قالت لي خلاص انت
هنفتح الشركه امسكها وتوكل على الله قلت
لها لا انا حابب حد يكون هو اللي بيدير
وانا هشتغل تحتيه اتعلم منه وربنا يسهل
وان شاء الله المشروع موضوع هيكبر واتعلم
منه واقدر اكمل بعد كده
جينا بعدها سنه ونص كده في 2019
اللي كان بيدير الشركه قرر ان هو ينسحب
ويمشي جات له فرصه في مكان تاني
وقالت لي خلاص دي بقت مسئوليتك هنكمل امتى
بقى
من هنا بقى كان نقله تانيه في حياتي
اتعلمت حاجات كتير وفي نفس الوقت لسه
المجال ده علامات كبيره جدا قدامي
الناس اللي كانت موجوده كان كذا حد ماشي
وكان شباك الواحد
والحد ده جاي بعد كام شهر كده وجاء له
اوفر في مكان ثاني فقال هيمشي بقيت لوحدي
في الشركه واطب تاني خالص ما كملناش شهر
او اتنين جات الكورونا
يعني خلاص دخلت بقى بقيت مدير اعمل شركه
بقى ومشوار هيمشي بشكل كويس بس لقيت المطب
جديد
طب هعمل ايه
قررت ان انا ابتدي اعمل النظام بتاعنا
داخليا ازاي هقدر
اعمل نظام ان احنا نعمل اداره حضانات او
مسرعات اعمال وفي نفس الوقت ازاي نعمل
نظام تقييم للشركات الناشئه دي وازاي نعرف
نحدد لها القيمه بتاعتها وازاي نقدر
نستثمر فيها ونحدد قيمه الاستثمار
وكل الحاجات دي واحده واحده ابتديت ابني
فريق
وهنا برضو كان في نصيحه خدتها كان مهمه
جدا
ان انت لما تيجي تعين حد عين الاشطر او
الاحسن منك طبعا بالنسبه لي ايه ده هو انا
وحش للدرجه دي طيب
بس مشيت مع النصيحه دي عينت يا شباب
الشباب بالنسبه لي كلهم اشطر مني كل واحد
في مجاله
دلوقتي وصلنا تسعه وعشره
الشركه بفضل الله السنه اللي فاتت خدت
احسن حاضنه اعمال يعني مستوى مصر واحسن
مسرعه اعمال على مستوى افريقيا
واستثمارنا بشركات كتير في مجال التعليم
وتكنولوجيا التعليم
الشركات دي برضو مشينا معاهم مشوار كويس
تعلمنا ازاي نختار الشركات دي وللاختيارات
دي بتبقى مبنيه على
الاخلاق
وطريقتهم في التعامل وان هم بيبقى عندهم
فكره مختلفه والفكره دي فعلا لها احتياج
موجود في السوق
ومن الستار ده بيبقى مبني على التكنولوجي
ومن الموجود فيه جايب ازاي اقدر اعالجه
وكملنا مع ال 14 شركه النهارده ال 14 شركه
دي
وصلت قيمتها ل 100 مليون دولار حوالي 3
مليار جنيه تقريبا طبعا هي طلعت من رقم
متواضع خالص لغايه الرقم ده فده كان يعتبر
انجاز كبير
كملنا برضو المشوار وعملنا شركه كملت خمس
سنين جاء لنا فيها اكبر شركه لها تركيز في
بتاع تكنولوجيا التعليم
وعملنا مع بعض
الحمد لله قدرنا نوصل لدرجه كويسه
وكل الكلام ده انا بقوله عشان مش حكيت لكم
القصه اكثر من ان كان في دروس كتير استفدت
بيها ان احنا نكون صادقين اول حاجه مع
نفسنا ومع اللي قدامنا
الناس اللي لها فضل علينا نفضل مقدرين
ومنحافظ عليهم على قد ما نقدر
لازم يكون عندنا سلوكيات
كويسه ونكون بنعمل الحاجه اللي احنا
بنعملها باتقان على قد ما بنقدر وربنا
بيكمل الاتقان ده بحاجه افضل ممكن ما
نبقاش عارفين مستقبلنا رايح فين
ممكن يكون اهلنا كانوا شايفين الحاجه بشكل
يعني ممكن يكون بالنسبه لنا قديم بس هو من
وجهه نظرهم ده كان افضل حاجه ده مش وحش بس
الصح ان انت تبقى كل الحاجات دي عندك
وتعرف ازاي هتقدر تكمل فيها بعدين فعشان
كده دايما انا بقول انت صاحب الخطوه
التاني شكرا لك